For more than 50 years, Bond girls have given
Agent 007 a run for his money in the race
to see who can be more compelling on the big
screen.
In celebration of that incredible legacy,
and the many actresses who've contributed
to it, let's see what those Bond girls are
up to today..
Ursula Andress helped set the template for Bond girls when she appeared as Honey Ryder
in 1962's Dr. No.
The scene in which she walks out of the ocean
in a bikini is one of the franchise's most
memorable entrances.
She continued acting regularly through the
1980s, most prominently in 1981's Clash of
the Titans.
Her acting work slowed in the '90s, and she
hasn't made a film since 2005.
An Italian model and beauty queen, Dianela
Bianchi's biggest acting role came as Tatiana
Romanova in the second Bond film, From Russia
With Love.
She retired from acting in 1970 to marry Italian
businessman Alberto Cameli, though she has
since appeared in documentary footage discussing
her time as a Bond girl.
For many, Honor Blackman as Pussy Galore,
a villain who proves Bond's equal and ultimately
switches sides for him in Goldfinger, is the
quintessential Bond girl.
Since that unforgettable role, Blackman has
continued working regularly on stage and screen,
and she's also enjoyed a singing career.
Her most recent acting appearance was in an
episode of You, Me & Them in 2015.
As Jill Masterson in Goldfinger, Shirley Eaton
didn't have much screen time, but her death
while covered in gold paint made her an icon.
After Bond, Eaton continued acting in films
like The Blood of Fu Manchu before retiring
in 1969 to focus on raising her two sons.
She published an autobiography in 1999, and
she also enjoys painting and sculpture.
Thunderball had a memorable and sexy villain
in the form of Luciana Paluzzi as SPECTRE
agent Fiona Volpe.
The resulting fame kept her acting throughout
the '60s and '70s.
Since 1980, she's been married to American
businessman Michael Jay Solomon.
She doesn't have any onscreen acting credits
since then, though she has given interviews
reflecting on her time as a Bond girl.
Diana Rigg was already a star by the time
she appeared as Bond's bride Tracy in 1969's
On Her Majesty's Secret Service.
Since then, she's continued to work steadily
in film, TV, and theater.
She became a dame in 1994, and her most famous
recent role was her Emmy-nominated turn as
Queen Olenna Tyrell on Game of Thrones.
Jill St. John played diamond smuggler Tiffany
Case in Diamonds Are Forever, making her the
first American Bond girl.
She continued acting steadily until 2002,
at which point she largely retired.
Since 1990 she's been married to actor Robert
Wagner.
Her most recent screen appearance was as Mrs.
Claus alongside Wagner as Santa in the 2014
Hallmark movie Northpole.
Jane Seymour rocketed to worldwide fame in
1973 as the enigmatic Solitaire
in Roger Moore's James Bond debut, Live and
Let Die.
Since then she's worked regularly in both
film and TV, most famously as the title character
on Dr. Quinn, Medicine Woman.
She's also an author of self-help and children's
books, and she designed the "Open Hearts Collection"
of jewelry for Kay Jewelers.
Britt Ekland's role as Miss Goodnight in The
Man with the Golden Gun cemented her status
as a sex symbol, and she continued acting
well into the '80s.
She was also famous for her high-profile relationships
with Peter Sellers and Rod Stewart.
In the past decade, she's shown up on a few
reality TV shows, including the Swedish series
Let's Dance in 2018.
Barbara Bach achieved fame as Agent Anya Amasova
in 1977's The Spy Who Loved Me.
She continued to act in the '80s, but she
hasn't appeared in a film since To the North
of Katmandu in 1986.
Since 1981, she's been married to former Beatle
Ringo Starr.
She's also been active in charity work, forming
the Self Help Addiction Recovery Program in
1991.
Lois Chiles was offered the female lead in
The Spy Who Loved Me, but she was taking a
hiatus from acting at the time and turned
it down.
But then a couple of years later, she accepted
the role of Dr. Holly Goodhead in 1979's Moonraker.
She continued acting throughout the '80s and
'90s, and her most recent film role was in
2006's Kettle of Fish.
French actress Carole Bouquet achieved international
fame as the vengeance-seeking Melina Havelock
in 1981's For Your Eyes Only.
She's continued acting in dozens of films,
plays, and TV series ever since.
In 2014 she served on the jury of the Cannes
Film Festival, and in 2017, she played a serial
killer in the French miniseries La Mante.
Maud Adams is unique among the actresses on
this list for playing two different Bond girls.
First she was Andrea Anders in The Man with
the Golden Gun, and then she was the title
crime lord in 1983's Octopussy.
She also even had an uncredited cameo in A
View to a Kill.
She continued to act regularly until largely
retiring in the late 2000s.
Tanya Roberts appeared as Stacey Sutton in
1985's A View to a Kill, and she continued
to act regularly throughout the '90s before
landing her most famous recent role as Donna's
mother Midge on That '70s Show.
She ultimately left the show in 2001, though
she did return for a brief run of episodes
in 2004.
Her acting career has been largely inactive
since then.
In A View to a Kill, Grace Jones was instantly
memorable as the deadly May Day.
She's continued to appear sporadically in
films and TV in the subsequent decades.
But her major pursuit, as it was before Bond,
is music.
Since 1977, she's released 10 studio albums
and remains one of the most distinctive performers
of her generation.
In 1987, Maryam d'Abo kicked off the Timothy
Dalton era as Kara Milovy in The Living Daylights.
She's continued to work as an actress and
model ever since.
In 2002, she hosted the documentary Bond Girls
Are Forever.
In 2007, she suffered a near-fatal brain hemorrhage,
from which she thankfully later recovered.
Carey Lowell played Pam Bouvier in 1989's
License To Kill, and she's continued to act
to this day.
She had a major role as Jamie Ross on Law
& Order beginning in 1996.
In the mid-2010s, her divorce from Richard
Gere was the subject of a three-year legal
battle.
As of 2018 she's returned to TV with roles
on Blue Bloods and Bull.
In 1995 the Pierce Brosnan era of Bond began,
complete with a new Moneypenny in the form
of Samantha Bond, who appeared in all four
Brosnan films.
Since the Brosnan era ended, she's continued
to act in a little bit of everything.
Her most recent high-profile role was Lady
Rosamund Painswick on the hit series Downton
Abbey.
The Brosnan era also brought with it a new,
female M. Judi Dench played the head of MI6
as a tough, resourceful woman who could keep
Bond in his place.
She was so good that she stayed on into the
Daniel Craig era until M's death in 2012's
Skyfall.
And since she is Dame Judi Dench, her career
has kept chugging along.
In 2019, she will be seen in adaptations of
Artemis Fowl and Cats.
"You get to boss him about and there is a
very special relationship between I think,
between Bond and M."
Izabella Scorupco was already a successful
model, singer, and actress when she was cast
as Natalya in 1995's GoldenEye.
Her other memorable acting work includes roles
in Exorcist: The Beginning and Reign of Fire.
In 2011 she returned to singing with a collaboration
with Swedish vocalist Peter Joback, and in
2012 she served as host of Sweden's Next Top
Model.
Famke Janssen achieved breakout success as
Xenia Onatopp in GoldenEye.
"Xenia Zergevna Onatopp."
"Onatopp?!"
"Onatopp."
The role rocketed her to stardom and helped
land her the role of Jean Grey in the X-Men
franchise.
Since then she's acted regularly in the likes
of Taken and Hemlock Grove.
She will soon be seen in the Netflix original
series Central Park Five.
Michelle Yeoh established herself throughout
the 1990s as a major player in Hong Kong action
cinema before breaking out worldwide in 1997's
Tomorrow Never Dies.
In 2000 she again wowed international audiences
in Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon and has
continued big-screen success ever since, most
recently in Crazy Rich Asians.
Teri Hatcher appeared in Tomorrow Never Dies
as Paris Carver, a former flame of Bond's
who's now the trophy wife of a villainous
media mogul.
She was already a TV superstar with Lois & Clark
and after Bond, she had another big hit in
the form of Desperate Housewives.
More recently, she's returned to the world
of DC Comics with a recurring role on The
CW's Supergirl.
Denise Richards was at the height of her fame
when she played Christmas Jones in 1999's
The World Is Not Enough.
Since then she's continued to appear in plenty
of films and taken on a career as a reality
TV personality.
She starred in her own series, Denise Richards:
It's Complicated, and in 2019, she joined
the cast of The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills.
French actress Sophie Marceau achieved blockbuster
success as the villainous Elektra King in
The World Is Not Enough.
She's continued to work steadily as an actress,
writer, and director ever since.
In 2002 she made her feature directorial debut
with Speak To Me of Love.
And in 2015, she served on the main competition
jury for the Cannes Film Festival.
Oscar winner Halle Berry was already a major
star when she played Jinx in Pierce Brosnan's
final Bond film, 2002's Die Another Day.
Her career has suffered a few missteps along
the way, but she's rebounded and continued
to work steadily in film and TV.
Among her most notable projects since Bond
are a return to the X-Men series and Kingsman:
The Golden Circle.
The Daniel Craig era required a memorable
Bond girl to kick things off, and it got one
with Eva Green as Vesper Lynd in Casino Royale.
The role made Green an international star.
She's since gone on to roles in the likes
of Penny Dreadful and Miss Peregrine's Home
for Peculiar Children.
In 2019, she can be seen in Tim Burton's live-action
Dumbo remake.
After a successful modeling career, Ukrainian-born
French actress Olga Kurylenko landed the role
of Camille Montes in 2008's Quantum of Solace.
She has since continued to earn high-profile
roles in films like Oblivion, The Death of
Stalin, and Johnny English Strikes Again.
As of 2018, she lives in London with her son
and boyfriend.
Naomie Harris was a 10-year veteran of film
acting by the time she landed the part of
the third big-screen Moneypenny in Skyfall,
and she immediately won fans over with her
portrayal.
She reprised the role in 2015's Spectre, and
has since garnered acclaim for her work in
Moonlight and appeared in major releases including
Rampage and Mowgli: Legend of the Jungle.
Léa Seydoux has been acting for more than
a decade, but in many ways her career is still
very young.
She achieved international acclaim in 2013
for her role in Blue is the Warmest Color,
and parlayed that into her role as Dr. Madeleine
Swann in 2015's Spectre.
She's expected to reprise her role for the
25th Bond film in 2020, a rare repeat performance
for a Bond girl.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.